oh gosh so having the nametag a lot of
people come up to me that are huge fans
of Winnie the Pooh and Tigger to this
one woman came up to me and she said oh
my gosh I just have to tell you I'm such
a huge fan of Winnie the Pooh so much so
that I changed my name to pooh pooh why
Pooh why not Winnie or even though I
like my name though a lot of people
change their names or give their names
away to things things like Lou Gehrig's
disease or Jenny Craig that's somebody's
name my name is TIG Notaro and I know I
wouldn't want to be driving down the
road one day and see a billboard that
said I did TIG Notaro for three weeks
and lost 50 pounds
[Music]
or maybe I was yeah you bet meaning I
like when people make that noise after
they laugh cuz it's like you're
reminiscing about one second ago
remember one second ago
[Laughter]
[Music]
yeah yeah I do I was always told that I
was mature for my age like even as an
infant
I took showers that is my favorite
visual in the entire world as an infant
taking a shower because it's like even
as adults we have to be careful when we
take a shower we could slip then when
you had an infant to that equation it
gets really tricky like you can't even
just sit an infant down in a tub and be
like hey scrub up
I'll be back they be like but I'm an
infant so I just love the idea of
walking into a bathroom and opening a
shower curtain and just seeing this
nothing makes me happier than an infant
taking a shower unless there are twins I
mean we're like a group shower at like
an orphanage just like 50 filthy orphans
trying to balance with their fat fat
sighs it's a stupid little one-inch feed
it's such a poor design to have fat fat
thighs and stupid little one-inch feed I
was performing in Seattle and when I was
on stage I move this stool next to me
just slightly and it made this weird
noise and it caused the entire audience
to laugh collectively I was like oh
that's all you guys need so I just kept
pushing the stool and they kept laughing
so I just kept pushing the stool and
they stopped laughing so I kept pushing
the stool they started laughing again it
just kept going like that for a while
good ten minutes so just curious what
you guys would think if i push the stool
here
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
feel likes maybe some of you aren't into
it that doesn't offend me if you're not
raise your hand I'm not if you want me
to stop a couple maybe it's cuz you
haven't heard it enough for those of you
that do like good I'm gonna that's gonna
be on my new CD and please look for it
the it's called stool movement thank you
to man
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]